welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and looking ahead to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
despite the Avengers defeating Thanos
and restoring reality so that spider-man
doesn't have to get transferred to a
different school things have never
actually been darker or more dangerous
that is if you ask Doctor Strange his
use of the time stone in his eye of
agamotto was crucial and infinity war
giving the sorcerer supreme enough
insight to know that one future exists
in which they win which inspired Tony
Stark with the hope to do what had to be
done however that good-luck charm is no
longer in dr. Strange's arsenal none of
the Infinity stones are after using them
Infinity Ward Thanos used the stones to
destroy the stones reducing them to
atoms so that he could retire and spend
more time on farmersonly.com the stones
they used an in-game work from past
timelines answer that their removal
wouldn't disrupt the space-time
continuum and piss off the ancient ones
ghosts too much cap returned it to them
to where they were taken so that leaves
the present MCU with no usable Infinity
stones which shouldn't be so much of a
problem because who need something that
powerful until you remember the time
stone in i iveco moto was a major
protection used by the sorcerers against
interdimensional threats
how will Doctor Strange protect earth
without the time stone the answer this
question might actually set up his next
film Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and with the title as metal as
that it's gonna be a very interesting
answer let's explore Stephen strange is
terrifyingly vulnerable home security
system in this episode of the inside
marvel
[Music]
okay let's begin with how the time stone
was introduced to us in the MCU
contained an eye of agamotto around the
neck of the ancient one before we knew
it was one of the six God rocks that
Thanos wanted for his gauntlet even
before we knew how useful it could be in
terms of time manipulation the eye of
agamotto was presented as a kind of
nuclear deterrent to protect against
mystical threats heroes like the
Avengers protect the world from physical
changes we sorceress safeguarded against
for mystical threats
sanctums protect the world and we
sorcerers protect the sanctums from what
other dimensional beings that threaten
our universe like your mom welcome back
on the scene it's interesting how
similar it is to the moment in
spider-man far from home in which
Clinton back pretending to be a warrior
from another dimension discusses the
threats to earth from what he says our
interdimensional elemental monsters the
conversation by the way in which half
the people in the room we're squirrels
pretending to be human I know a lot of
layers there in both cases our
vulnerable pale blue dot is presented to
the under attack on a global scale both
our visual representations of the image
that Tony Stark had evoked a number of
times I see a suit of armor around the
world but following the death of the
ancient one Wong into the Doctor Strange
film with a foreboding warning order the
answer ones death will spread through
the multiverse there's no sorceress or
praying to defender now at the time that
warning seem to be hinting at the coming
arrival of people like Thanos but now
looking back this was terrible but
nowhere near the Lovecraftian cosmic
horror that could still be lurking out
there I believe that this moment was
Wong speaking for director scott
derrickson and screenwriters see Robert
Cargill hinting at their plans for Italy
next Doctor Strange film which brings us
to multiverse of madness dr. Strange's
possession of the time stone was the one
thing keeping the multiverse in check he
used it to trap Dormammu in the Dark
Dimension in an infinite time loop a
form of psychological warfare that even
the most nightmarish of Horrors cannot
stand without that time stone what is to
stop Dormammu for making another attempt
at acquiring earth to his Dark Dimension
he would need another disciple who could
follow in case aliases footsteps of
course but I don't know do we trust all
those losers
Oh defected and couldn't even bring
himself to show up in a battle to save
the frickin universe absence was noted
Mordo also it's worth pointing out that
scott derrickson recently tweeted a
memory of how they shot the Dark
Dimension in the first Doctor Strange
film perhaps returning to the Dark
Dimension could be something on his mind
as he's shooting multiverse of madness
which is currently in pre-production now
there is a way strange and Wong could
reacquire the time stone The Avengers
quantum tunnel does remain functional
they could simply return to 2018 open a
portal but Thanos his farm on the garden
and right before he snaps him into atoms
strapped him up with the crimson bands
of cyttorak or whatever you like at the
green one and then peace out would that
create more problems with the space-time
continuum like the ones the ancient one
warned about yeah probably but our
dimension will be safe some theaters
right and that multi-dimensional chaos
could be what the multiverse of madness
is referring to but let's assume that
the Infinity stones are things of the
past elements of the Infinity saga
phases one two and three that will have
no bearing on the future of the MCU
phase four and in that case Doctor
Strange will be left to his own skills
no time stone to defend Earth now from a
story standpoint it's kind of a good
thing strange with the time stone is
just a bit too powerful to make any
conflict a truly fair fight like
infinity war kind of shied away from it
but strange could have used that time
stone to destroy Thanos in the black
order sure turning Thanos his attacks
and the butterflys is cool but you know
what else is cool using the time stone
to trap tanis's left a word and a time
loops of the de never pumps blood
through his arteries and he drops dead
from brain failure I know that sounds
creepily anatomically accurate to Dirk
but this is Doctor Strange we're talking
about he's a surgeon you know that
brilliant mind of his is working out
attacks of the specificity of a scalpel
now losing the time stone will poor
strange to rely on a variety of other
spells and artifacts that makes it so
fun to watch mirror dimension crimson
beta Center a cloak of levitation
vaulting boots a belt or butterflies
that weird S&M domination thing that he
put guy silliest in you know which what
I'm talking about
and as warned in the final minutes of
Doctor Strange no time stone opens a
door once more to Dormammu but also
other dimensional threats characters
like Mephisto Marvel's version of the
devil also nightmare the villain from
the dream dimension whom there
and has cited s is ideal villain for the
sequel essentially the events of
Avengers in game have left earth in the
MCU without its primary nuclear
deterrent
just imagine what horrors are waiting to
creep and once that deterrence removal
is do you prefer the MCU without the
time stone or with it comment down below
with your thoughts follow me on
instagram and twitter at a boss follow
new rock stars on socials and subscribe
to me rock stars to join us as we go
deeper and deeper inside Marvel thanks
for joining me bye
[Music]